اقتحمى عشرات المستوطنين ساحات المسجد
الاقصى من جهه باب المغاربه وسط حراسه
مشدده من شرطه الاحتلال اقتحم المستوطنون
الاقصى على شكل مجموعات وقاموا بجولات في
ساحات الحرم وتلقوا
شروحات عن الهيكل المزموع المزعوم وقد
شعائره المضيق قباله قبه الصخره قبل ان
يغادروا من جهه باب السلسله تتزمل
اقتحامات المستوطنين مع الاحتفالات بعيد
الفصح اليهودي ادعت منظمات الهيكل لتنظيم
اقتحامات كبيره للمسجد الاقصى على مدار
ايام عيد الفصح تستمر حتى الثاني عشر من
ابريل الجري
من باب سلسله احد باب المسجد الاقصى معنا
نجوان سمري نجوان ليس فقط اقتحامات ليله
الماضيه ولكن ايضا هذا الصباح كانت هناك
اقتحامات من قبل مستوطنين
نعم بالفعل حتى هذه الساعه كان هناك قرابه
140 مستوطنا اقتحموا المسجد الاقصى
المبارك منذ ان فتح باب المغاربه بحراسه
مشدده من شرطه الاحتلال ثماني مجموعات من
المستوطنين اقتحموا هذا اليوم المسجد
الاقصى في اول يوم من عيد الفصح اليهودي
بالعاده في اول يوم هناك عطله رسميه وتكون
الاعداد قليله قياسا بباقي ايام عيد الفصح
اليهودي حيث ان هناك دعوات واسعه من قبل
المنظمات التي تطلق على نفسها منظمات
الهيكل او عائدون الى الهيكل وهي التسميه
العبريه للمسجد الاقصى المبارك لتكثيف هذه
الاقتحامات خلال ايام عيد الفصح الذي
يستمر
لاسبوع فجر هذا اليوم تم تحديد قيود مشدده
من قبل شرطه الاحتلال على دخول المصلين
لاداء صلاه الفجر وقابلنا العديد من
الشبان الذين وصلوا من اماكن مختلفه سواء
كان من مدينه القدس او حتى من داخل الخط
الاخضر ممن اضطروا لاداء الصلاه عند
الابواب ومنعوا من دخول من الدخول الى
المسجد واداء صلاه
الفجر وذلك كان تمهيدا لبدء اقتحامات
المستوطنين حيث انتشرت قوات كبيره من
الاحتلال في باحات المسجد الاقصى المبارك
وبدات بتامين هذه الاقتحامات من باب
المغاربه وصولا الى باب السلسله من هذا
الباب يخرج المستوطنون بعد اداء الجوله
والاقتحام في جوله دائريه داخل الاسوار
داخل باحات المسجد الاقصى المبارك قبل ان
ناتي الى هنا كنا في منطقه باب جبل
الزيتون وراينا كيف انهم يقومون بين الحين
والاخر بالتوقف في اماكن محدده في داخل
المسجد الاقصى ويؤدون
تلموديه على مراه من شرطه الاحتلال في
الازقه في الطريق الى هنا الى باب السلسله
من الواضح ومن اللافت الانتشار الكبير جدا
لقوات الاحتلال عند كافه محاور الطرق وفي
ازقه البلده القديمه وهناك تجديدات واضحه
ايضا عند ابواب المسجد الاقصى المبارك
ووجود كبير لشرطه الاحتلال في عده محاور
وفي عده طرق هذا الصباح قابلنا هنا او
لفتت نظرنا هذه الفتاه اوزجيجان وصلت من
تركيا
للتعبد في شهر رمضان هنا في المسجد الاقصى
المبارك جاءت عند صلاه الفجر لاداء الصلاه
يوم امس تم احتجاز جواز سفرها واليوم منعت
كليا من الدخول الى المسجد الاقصى هي
تستطيع ان تتحدث بشكل بسيط باللغه العربيه
سنسمع منها ما حدث اوزكيجان لماذا تجلسين
هنا ولم تدخلي الى الاقصى
بصدق لم ننظر نعم تفضلي
يعني انا انا اخون لان يعني شرطه اسرائيلي
لا لن بسمه يعني ادخل الى المسجد الاقصى
يعني انا بهب مسجد الاقصى
ان شاء الله يعني مرابطين ان شاء الله
مرابطين
من تركيا نعم من تركيا جاءت من تركيا اذا
شكرا يعني تحدثت الينا بالتركيه وكان هنا
زميل يجيد التركيه ترجمه لنا قصتها حاولت
من طريق كل الابواب للمسجد الاقصى ان تدخل
لاداء صلاه الفجر هذا اليوم لكنها منعت
وقيل لها غير مسموح لها بالدخول دون
اعطائها اي سبب وهذا مثال على قصص اخرى
لعشرات المبعدين عن المسجد الاقصى المبارك
رغم انها تحمل الجنسيه التركيه فوجئت هذا
اليوم بانه لا يسمح لها بالدخول واداء
الصلاه في داخل المسجد الاقصى هناك عشرات
المبعدين والمبعدات عن
ويضطرون لاداء الصلاه عند الابواب بشكل
دائم وليس فقط في شهر رمضان ولكن يكون
هناك تكثيف لتوزيع اوامر الابعاد من قبل
سلطات الاعتلال
للفلسطينيين وقد استبقت هذا الاسبوع اسبوع
عيد الفصح اليهودي بتوزيع عشرات اوامر
الابعاد عن المسجد الاقصى لعشرات الشبان
والفتيات من القدس ومن داخل الخط الاخضر
ربما هناك قصص كثيره وغيرها من من يحاولون
فعلا استغلال هذه الايام الفضيله في
الصلاه في المسجد الاقصى فضلا طبعا عن
فلسطين هناك نقطه نجوان يعني كما قلت اكثر
من في اكثر من مداخله يعني اقتحام المسجد
الاقصى هذا اصبح شيء معتاد بالنسبه
للفلسطنين خصوصا في رمضان لكن هذه السنه
الامر يبدو مختلف طريقه التعامل مع
المصلين اكثر قسوه من اي وقت مضى حدثينا
عن هذا هذه النقطه تحديدا
باختصار لو سمحت
دعيني فقط اقول ليلى رغم ان الاقتحامات هي
يوميه وبشكل يومي من ايام الاحد الى
الخميس طيله ايام السنه ولكن تكون الدعوات
لتكثيف هذه الاقتحامات في ايام الاعياد
وبطبيعه الحال تكون هناك انتهاكات اكثر
اكثر ورغم ان هذا الامر يبدو غير استثنائي
الا ان الرفض الفلسطيني يستمر بمعنى انهم
لا يريدون ان يطبعوا مع هذه الظاهره رغم
انها باتت كمشهد اعتيادي بالنسبه للعالم
لذلك نرى هذه المواجهات بين الحين والاخر
لان الفلسطينيين يرفضون ان يفرض عليهم
الخروج من المسجد الاقصى المبارك لاتاحه
هذه الاقتحامات وهذا ربما ما اججج الاوضاع
منذ بدايه شهر رمضان المبارك بدات قوات
الاحتلال بقرار صادر عن الشرطه
الاسرائيليه عن شرطه الاحتلال بتفريغ
المسجد الاقصى المبارك بكافه مرافقه بعد
انتهاء صلاه التراويح اي ان المسلمون يمنع
اي ان المسلمين يمن من البقاء وقيام صلاه
قيام الليل ما تعرف بالتهجد بعد انتهاء
صلاه التراويح يمنعون من البقاء في المسجد
الاقصى وبالمناسبه هناك ايضا
مسلمون غير فلسطينيين بمعنى ياتون من خارج
البلاد
ويريدون المبيت في المسجد الاقصى المبارك
الا انهم يمنعون من ذلك وهذا ما اججج
الاوضاع قبيله العيد الفصح اليهودي قبل
يومين تحسنت مجموعه من المعتكفين والمصلين
داخل المسجد القبلي
وبطبيعه الحال شرطه الاحتلال رفضت ذلك
ودخلت وقامت بالاعتداء هذا الاعتداء الذي
رايناه امام الجميع بالضرب المبرح على
المصلين والمعتكفين لماذا لانهم فقط
يريدون اداء الصلاه والبقاء في داخل
المسجد الاقصى المبارك ومن الواضح بان
شرطه الاحتلال علما فقط لو لو اختم بذلك
لا يوجد اقتحامات للمستوطنين في ساعات
الليل وهذا يعني بان شرطه الاحتلال تمنع
بقاء المسلمين دون اي مبرر وان كان ايضا
في الصباح تمنعهم دون اي مبرر لكن من
الواضح بان الشرطه وسلطات الاحتلال بقرار
تريد ان تفعل ربما ما تسميه بقوه الردع
الاسرائيليه لاظهار انها هي صاحبه القرار
وصاحبه السياده في داخل المسجد الاقصى
من امام المسجد الاقصى في القدس شكرا